What is the chokehold that blonde has on some of you guys?
And I'm not. Oh my god.
I've been wanting to make a video about this for a long time.
I'm starting to see this topic pop up.
I actually used to make a couple videos about this.
But we need to talk about the idea.
Blondeness as it pertains to the white beauty standard.
Right now my hair is like,
all burned. But I've been blonde before,
I've been brown, I've been black,
I've been all the hair colors.
But blonde is so much more than a hair color.
Within the white beauty standard,
blonde is by far the superior hair color
because it appeals most to the male gaze.
Most men will actually tell you that they prefer long
blonde hair on a woman.
And this kind of speaks to our obsession with youth,
especially, in my opinion,
the like, pedophilic nature of the male gaze.
So when you look at the white beauty standard,
you look at, like, thin,
you look at hairless, you look at blonde.
Those are children. Having blonde hair
as an adult woman puts you closer to the concept of youth,
and youth puts you closer to desirability.
Let that sink in for a second.
That's also why the same thing is equal,
yet opposite for the white beauty standard for men.
Blonde men are not as attractive as the tall,
dark, handsome archetype because most adults aren't blonde
and women are Not attracted to children in the same way that men are.
You're welcome. That's gonna fuck you up for a while.